I'm a bit tied up I need someone to come
and save me I wish it I wish they'd
hurry up and reading about you you have
kind of reinvented yourself as an action
hero well I did I did this film called
take a straight-to-video
is that when you thought it was gone I
thought yeah yeah absolutely and Fox
Studios at open in France and then an
urban and South Korea and then it was
done lootable you know on computers in
South Korea because my nephew's in
Brighton downloaded it I said that's
against the law you can't do those
things as well we're students
am I still going
because how long is it since you did the
last board it's six seven years yeah
more than that
it came out in oh seven but we shot it
in oh six so yeah it's been nine years
and in movie time it's even more because
the the third one and the second one are
supposed to dovetail like the third ax
take place at the same time so
technically James Bourne has a James
Bourne Jason bond is fine when you're
making a movie like this Daniel you do
hurt yourself a lot like in the previous
ones what's happened to you I've had my
right shoulder reconstructed I have had
this left knee operated on my right knee
operated on that work then in a sentence
oh well that that works in a sentence a
statement a question it works anywhere
right when you wake up right well before
you go to bed it's just you could just
say it if you smell what The Rock is
cookin yeah but you got to say it
probably with a little bit like you know
little shout that one as well
it's hard I generally have a microphone
when I'm doing it well oh go for it
I don't know they don't want to hear me
okay all right here we go
so it's it all starts with the bass okay
okay got to open your legs a little bit
okay okay you gotta kind of do one of
these yeah lean forward a little bit
yeah come back here's where you got to
do a little tongue thing with the rock
and then there's a little pause there's
like a big pregnant pause that you have
to do so the audience kind of leans in a
little bit is
going back to the very beginning your
bodybuilding career
how many talk to you were mr. universe
seven times something I won the world
championship still 13 times
Miss Teen Miss Olympia seven times mr.
world and orders and you might think of
like how could someone be that
disciplined how could someone go to the
gym that much why would you be that
interested in in lifting all those
weights well I think this clip from a
very early documentary pumping iron
which yeah yeah it's a great film
I think this clip will explain why on
horseback I enjoyed the gym but so much
the greatest feeling you can get in a
gym of the most satisfying feeling you
can get in the gym is the pump let's say
you drain your biceps blood is rushing
into your muscles and that's what we
call the pump you muscles get a really
tight feeling like your skin is going to
explode any minute you know it's really
tight it's like somebody blowing air
into into your muscle it just blows up
and it feels different it feels
fantastic
it's a satisfying to me as the coming is
having sex with a woman coming so can
you believe how much I am in heaven I'm
like getting the feeling of coming in
the gym I'm getting the feeling of
coming at home and a feeling of coming
backstage when it pump up when I pose
out the front of 5,000 beaver I get the
same feeling so I'm coming day and night
I'll be coming in spy for Naomi and
Daniel you that very sexy potentially
dangerous scene with the shaving cream
shaker
so could you still do it LLL do it okay
okay
it's around the lips that you have to be
really happy to believe
are you going to do that you are you
because I was trained by the amazing
timing of God
oh well done you
when you forget your line you kind of go